hey guys B here this is going to be my
things you might have missed video for
Game of Thrones season 7 episode 5 east
watch it should go without saying but if
you haven't watched episode 5 yet this
will definitely spoil it for you so
that's your spoiler warning and as I
said in the last one a lot of these
things are obvious but it's fun to look
back through the episode and just
reminisce on the old callbacks and
things like that so that's what we're
going to do first off I have to talk
about John touching the dragon because
in my top moments recap I mentioned that
it was weird that John just decided to
touch the dragon now what I didn't say
there was that he was able to do so
because he has Targaryen blood at the
time I figured that's pretty much common
knowledge but then I got a lot of
comments of people being like how can
you not know that and be a fan of Game
of Thrones it's like well yeah of course
I know that I have videos from last year
about whether John was going to ride a
dragon and what Dragon Riders are and
all that kind of stuff but I realized
you know I didn't point it out so it is
important to point out and there's
something that we all have to keep in
mind when we watch the show is that
nothing is known in the show until it's
known you know what I mean like there's
lots of things that they've kind of
twisted a bit and I won't go down that
road right this minute
but the reason why John is able to touch
the dragon is because from what we can
assume that it senses his Targaryen
blood that ties into the fact of why the
Targaryen is married each other and why
all this uproar about John and Danny
getting together even though they're
related by blood is kind of misplaced
there were a lot of Dragon Lord families
in old Valyria the Targaryens were
actually a minor one they just happen to
leave before the doom have it so this
bonding and ability to become Dragon
Riders is not something that anybody can
do
so that bloodline was very important for
them it doesn't mean that incest is okay
and all that other stuff but it does
mean that there is some reasoning in
their minds for it now I did see a photo
online in Kim renfro's article on the
insider where they say that they see a
wolf there it's a nice close-up of it it
looks like the
selection could be but I don't think
it's conclusive but that could be a nod
to his half Targaryen half stark
bloodline as well the next thing you
might have missed was one that I did
show in the top moments recap and that
was that ginjuries hammer that he made
has the Baratheon Staggs digital on it
and it's pretty cool you can't really
see it when he's carrying it around but
when they fit it in the boat if you
clean you know if you zoom in you can
see that it's clearly there so that is
pretty awesome
Gentry's wardrobe when it comes across
them in King's Landing could also be a
little bit of favoring towards the
Baratheon taos colors which were yellow
and black the next thing he might have
missed was the callback from Davos where
he talks about the last time I was here
you killed my son with wildfire of
course that's not very discreet it's
directly about the Battle of the
Blackwater Bay which I mentioned it
might have been a problem but I think
it's funny here is that there's very
little that you can say to shut Tyrion
up but this was that thing almost lost
his son Athos in that battle as a direct
result of the wildfire that Tyrion used
to destroy the Baratheon fleet
Davos was actually full of a ton of
callbacks and one in particular was just
complete fanservice but was still
awesome when he said I thought maybe you
might still be rowing at that Beach we
saw a gold cloak that may have looked
familiar to you the actor's name is
Kevin Eldon and he was in the sixth
season playing Ned Stark in the mummer's
show that Arya saw so that's definitely
good on a couple levels because it was a
pretty shitty depiction of Ned Stark I
mean that was a pretty honorable dude
and handled himself pretty well and this
made him look like a buffoon the next
one is another one I didn't mention in
the recap but I'll go all the way into
what the letter actually says now we all
saw that Arya found the scroll it wasn't
exactly clear on screen what it was
because you just see a flash really
quickly and it's only part of it but it
is actually something that we know about
and what it says is it's also wrote it
when she was at king
landing and the entirety of what it says
is Rob I write to you with a heavy heart
our good King Robert is dead killed from
wounds he took in a boar hunt father has
been charged with treason he conspired
with Roberts brother's against my
beloved Joffrey and tried to steal his
throne the Lannisters are treating me
very well and provide me with every
comfort
I beg you come to King's Landing swear
fealty to King Joffrey and prevent any
strife between the Great Houses of
Lannister and Stark now obviously Cersei
put the words into her head and that she
rose down she dictated the letter I'm
sure
and it's interesting to remember that
whenever it arrived Robb and Catelyn
didn't believe that Cersei actually
wrote it they knew that this was done by
thirsty on behalf of Joffrey and Sansa
was basically just a pawn in their
little thing
Arya on the other hand this may I mean
the whole idea that Littlefinger has is
that it's going to cast suspicion on
Sansa and Arya may not trust her and
that could be a place where he could
drive a wedge I would add though that
she was there Arya was there she knows
how things were going so I'm not sure
it'll be a hundred percent effective I
wasn't expecting until I realized what
the letter said I wasn't expecting that
he was actually doing all of that as a
show so that Arya would fall into his
trap so that was kind of interesting
there was a callback to Arthur Dayne in
this episode in the goodbye between John
and Daenerys he uses the phrase I wish
you good fortune in the wars to come and
that's the same thing that Arthur Dayne
said to Ned at the Tower of joy the next
one is one that I didn't recognize I
read this one in Kim's article as well
when Sam's leaving the Citadel he says
to Gilly I'm tired of reading about the
achievement of better men back in season
six whenever he we meet Randall Tommy
for the first time when he goes there
Randall had said to him I thought the
Nights Watch would make you into a man
so and so forth and he goes into the
rant about something resembling a man at
least you managed
safes often fat your nose buried in
books spending your life reading about
the achievements of better men so in the
episode where Randall gets fried and is
no longer with us Sam has the call back
to his cruel old dad and that's kind of
cool when you think about it this next
one is one that probably nobody missed
and that's the fact that Daenerys called
back her own speech about the wheel but
I think it's interesting to look at the
two versions of what was said in Episode
five as she's talking to the defeated
Lannister soldiers she says
all I want to destroy is the wheel that
has rolled over rich and poor to benefit
of no one but the Cersei Lannister of
the world
she actually said this when she first
meets Tyrion and the way she says it
back then is she lifts off the names and
it goes like this she says Lannister
Baratheon stark Tyrell they're all just
spokes on a wheel
this one's on top and that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground I'm not going to stop the
wheel I'm going to break the wheel so
like I said I don't think anybody missed
that but I think it's important that she
still has that revolutionary spirit if
you want to call it that a lot of people
are quick to jump to this idea that
she's going to become a Mad Queen but I
think that there's going to be a lot of
different I pointed this out in the
trailer breakdown that people kind of
went nuts about it's a different
situation I was trying to draw attention
to the fact that it's a completely
different situation in Tyrion and Varys
right now they're worried because
they're afraid that if she goes around
burning people which Randall and Dickon
made that choice you know what I mean
I'm not saying that that was crazy for
her to do it I'm saying that these
soldiers aren't going to be following
her because of any other reason besides
fear so it's good to see her say that
and know that and we hope that she won't
fall into those same mistakes that
obviously her Mad King father made but
also you know things aren't that good
for the average person in this world
even when there isn't a Mad King
in there like you think about the war of
the five kings the Lannisters were just
destroying the countryside they were
killing people all over the place
so it's an interesting dynamic and we'll
see how it goes I'm not really sure that
it's going to play out to a fool with
all this business going on north of the
Waldos so we'll have to see how that
goes at least in the show and the last
one the tenth thing that you might have
missed in the last episode of Game of
Thrones is obviously the big reveal that
Gilly made they got overlooked now this
was kind of funny and that she said
Prince Rhaegar but what she says is that
that ceptin who wrote the journal was he
had issued an annulment for Prince
Rhaegar and you married him to someone
else at the same time in a secret
ceremony Indore so there's no doubt that
this is I mean the tower of joy is in
Dorne so there's no doubt that this is
Lyanna stark that they're talking about
of course there's no reason why that
should stand out to Sam in the same way
it does to us and he's thinking about
other things so it all gets looked over
so what does that actually mean like
this started one of the biggest debates
with a lot of the people that I you know
have been reading their theories and
just people who know a lot about these
books in this universe I think the show
viewers won't really be affected that
much but in the context of things what
was always believed before this was that
Rhaegar took abducted kidnapped Liana
away after the incident has the tourney
at Harrenhal where he named her the
queen of love and beauty so this is
stuff that people have been theorizing
about because up until last season we
never knew for sure that John's parents
Rhaegar and Lyanna
I mean that was the most popular theory
but there are other ones as well and so
when the show confirmed that that made
it a question of what Jon's legitimacy
was if Rhaegar and Lyanna weren't
married he'd still be a bastard he would
be a different bastard instead of being
a stark master he would be a Targaryen
bastard because he was just be someone
that was born to highborn people who are
outside of a marriage so you have to
imagine that when this happen
and that's when Brandon Stark and Ned's
father Rickard went to King's Landing
were burned alive by the Mad King like
all of this directly fed into Robert's
rebellion before he married Cersei
before he was the king he was betrothed
to Lyanna Stark and we've seen in the TV
show that he did actually love her early
see loved the idea of her way back in
the very first episode he goes into the
crypts and he's still burning a candle
for so this incident this annulment that
they're talking about makes John
legitimate but it also brings up the
reality of the consequences of this
action thousands of people died as a
result of Rhaegar running away with
Liana wars were fought dynasties ended
you know I mean it was a big deal so a
lot of the anti Rhaegar people came out
and they were just really disappointed
that this news turned out to be true
because I guess people were like oh well
that means his parents were in love and
they were married but yeah it still
doesn't change what happened as a result
of their parenting and remember this
really is more of him trying to fulfill
that prophecy and I believe that his
wife couldn't give him another child so
that's probably why he had to annul the
wedding in the first place so yeah his
heavy stuff we all like Jon Snow either
way but all that went into bringing him
into the world is pretty frigging heavy
when you think about it so yeah there's
some other things here that are
interesting too but this video has
already gotten wrong let me know what
your favorite callbacks or little
details that popped up were which one of
these did you get which ones did you not
see please like the video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already make sure you follow me
on Twitter and on Facebook and Instagram
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon